bonjour à tous les deux merci bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en
direct pour ce débat ce matin sur rtl
france alors on a vu cette campagne
dévoilé par la république en marche à
angers ils vont distribuer beaucoup de
tracts ce week end avec ce slogan 50
plus bruno bonnell est-ce que c'est pas
un peu prématuré puisque emmanuel macron
ne s'est toujours pas déclaré candidat
dès ce week-end c'était là à la rentrée
parlementaire
des députés du groupe de la république
en marche et donc c'était normal de de
profiter de ce moment pour faire un vrai
bilan et arrêter de continuer comme
d'ailleurs je viens de l'entendre dans
votre reportage le mythe comme quoi rien
n'a été fait et qu'il ya des blocages
partout parce que c'est exactement
inverse donc que non on déconnecte ont
des couples les résultats de ce café
pendant ce quinquennat le président a
republic et continuera à le faire
jusqu'au bout c'est sont ses propres
paroles et vite en préparation d'une
éventuelle candidature dont il jugera le
tempo alors 90% des promesses de la
campagne présidentielle ont été tenus
selon les militants la république en
marge qu'en pensez-vous emilie marsh est
ce que ce chiffre vous paraît crédible
sur le plus quoi mais si on les
promesses des manuels macron oui mais
c'est son programme de politique envers
les riches et je rejoins monsieur bruno
bonnet quand on dit quand il dit que
rien n'a été que l'on ne peut pas dire
que rien n'a été fier en effet oui il ya
une politique mais une politique de
droite une politique et les chiffres
sont sans glaçant et contrairement à ce
qui est écrit dans le tract qui va être
diffusé parce que je l' ai lu
attentivement
non on peut pas dire que il ya eu une
politique plus juste et les chiffres je
suis désolé qu'ils sont glace en avant
l'arrivée d'emmanuel macron 500 familles
les plus riches de france td
570 milliards elles sont à plus de 1000
milliards de patrimoine donc la
politique d' emmanuel macron augmenter
le patrimoine des plus riches
2 x 2 et pendant ce temps là les jeux
les français vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté sont passées de 9 à 12 millions
dont il ya une véritable casse il à lui
aussi une casse on a volé les français
sur leurs droits quand on parle j'alerte
que quand on parle on dit on a on a
augmenté le cynique il ya plus de
pouvoir d'achat derrière ces des
cotisations sociales qui sont partis il
ya aussi le scandale sur la formation
professionnelle où il ya près de 10
millions de français qui n'ont pas créé
leur compte professionnel de formation
parce qu'il ya pas eu de communication
etc ont perdu leur droit à la formation
c'est juste à peu près 1200 euros de
perdus de crédit à l'information pour un
français qui n'a pas créé son compte
professionnel de formation est très peu
de communication ont été faites dessus
donc en fait 50 plus dans ce sens là bon
on doit la france insoumise évidemment
c'est non et juste moi j'ai alerte les
français a vraiment aller à les regarder
aller se renseigner mais oui cette
politique qui avait promis emmanuel
macron de cases de code du travail elle
a été fait et donc il a il a tenu ses
engagements mais pas pour un monde plus
juste plus égalitaire plus sociale vous
ne répondez vous à emilie marsh les
promesses sont tenues mais n'ont pas
forcément été en faveur des plus
défavorisés
et moi je suis un démocrate démocrate
veut dire que j'attends les échéances
présidentielles pour voir comment les
gens vont choisir quand on a présenté un
programme en 2010 l on a effectivement
présenté un programme et nous avons tenu
ce qui était écrit dans ce programme
c'est assez inhabituel vous savez parce
qu'il ya quand même depuis deux mois je
je vote je me suis rendu compte à chaque
fois qu'il y avait toujours un prétexte
pour ne pas faire ce qu'on avait dit
qu'on use ce qu'on avait promis aux
français quant aux remarques sur à la
fois la casse sociale et et les
inégalités moi je voudrais aussi
rappeler que c'est ce truc sous
armements que on a donné redonner la
taxe d'habitation aux personnes et les
plus en difficulté on a également
augmenté tout ce qui était soutien aux
personnes âgées au chaos aux personnes
handicapées donc dire que regarder
simplement
une partie de l'histoire me paraît quand
même un peu exagéré deuxième en a vécu
là qu il est également le mouvement des
gilet jaune qu'on était quand même
extrêmement handicapants et malgré sa 90
textes ont été votés pour réformer la
société française alors nous sommes pas
du même bord politique avec vous a
marché et je hais je le comprends ceci
dit c'est important que les politiques
reviennent à dire voilà notre programme
voté pour nous et si vous votez pour
nous nous ferons notre programme c'est
dans ce sens là on parle de cinq ans de
plus parce que nous comme c'est dans
notre programme on considère qu'on a
amélioré la qualité 10 des français
alors beaucoup parlé des réformes
fiscales suppression isf il ya eu
beaucoup de références fiscales
effectivement sous le mandat d' emmanuel
macron suppression de la taxe
d'habitation vous l'avez dit mais une
promesse qui coûte cher selon l'institut
montaigne qui a publié le bilan de cet
été regardé
les économies budgétaires qui devait
accompagner la réduction des
prélèvements obligatoires ne sont pas
être venu en 2020 la france occupé la
première place européenne
s'agissant du niveau de ses dépenses
publiques
61,28 points de pib une tendance qui ne
devrait pas s'inverser à court terme
emilie marsh s'inquiète beaucoup à
l'ailé les frais justement que vont
devoir supporter les français avec
notamment au sila est la crise sanitaire
le compte n'y est pas
non le clairement le conte le compte n'y
est pas et on est on le voit par
l'augmentation quand même de la pauvreté
on le voit aussi par les difficultés des
personnes qu'ils ont à se loger ou le
nombre de mal logés a augmenté on le
voit aussi parce que là on a une
augmentation du gaz de pluie pour cent
et que les salaires en fait ils
n'augmentent pas et que pendant ce temps
là les chiffres glaçant de
l'augmentation des dividendes versés aux
actionnaires fait froid aux yeux en même
temps et en plus les entreprises
licencient juste l'année dernière au
mois d'octobre il y avait 30 plan de
licenciement par semaine alors qu'on
alors qu'il ya eu çà plus de 500
milliards d'argent versées à des
entreprises sans aucune contrepartie moi
je serais revenu ir est ce que ça ne
fait pas un bon indicateur sont mais la
croissance après pour aller à qui parce
que si c'est pour augmenter la
croissance et c'est juste pour que
l'argent aille dans les dividendes des
actionnaires et qu'en même temps et
suppriment des emplois c'est juste un
monde c'est juste pas possible est
inadmissible et moi je suis extrêmement
choqué quand dans le tract il y a le
fait que la con qu'on a remis les
fleurons industriels alors que quand
même moi j'habite dans une région où il
ya general electric on a perdu les
turbines de 2 grenoble on a perdu dans
votre circonscription monsieur bruno
bonnell
où il ya un grand plan social à general
electric et leurs ballons ne peut pas
dire que le gouvernement a vraiment agi
pour sauver a été à l'écouté des
salariés qui eux se battaient justement
pour sauver ce savoir faire industriel
et cette souveraineté et il ya juste une
promesse qui n'étaient pas dans le
programme d' emmanuel macron et qui a
été fait c'est et qui est remis à
l'ordre du jour c'est la réforme des
retraites est autre chose aussi sur
lequel les français n'ont pas voté c'est
sur notre politique migratoire quand les
gens second tour ils ont voté contre
marine le pen c'est pas pour appliquer
une politique migratoire comme vous
l'avez fait réponse bruno bonnell et on
va parler de la réforme des retraites
justement qui a été confirmé par
gabriela talent hier
je pense que une part à caractéristique
des des chaînes d'information c'est
qu'on est saturé de chiffres en
permanence alors j'ai pas très envie de
rappeler qu'on a effectivement dans le
même temps réal tente et relocaliser 553
usines sur le territoire français j'ai
pas envie de rappeler que le quoi qu'il
en coûte qui a coûté 240 milliards a
permis de sauver des milliers d'emplois
il gardait des gens malgré sanitaire
dans l'emploi et dans des moyens j'ai
pas envie de rappeler que effectivement
quand l'assumons tel sort maintenant sur
2020 d'une analyse sur la dette elle me
parlait tellement tellement grotesque je
préfère me pas la commenter puisque nous
savons que la dette a été justement
engagées pour soutenir et protéger les
français mais plus loin que ça plus loin
que ça et juste pour conclure l'idée
c'est de créer effectivement une
dynamique qui aujourd'hui va créer des
emplois industriels plus tranquille sur
les deux dernières années s'est jamais
arrivé on n'a jamais eu un taux de
chômage aussi bas depuis l'an 2000 c'est
à dire que les gens reviennent dans le
travail donc on ne peut pas dire on ne
peut pas juste montrer images d'avant la
crise effectivement et ont donc on ne
peut pas d'illusions et
c'est des oui non mais madame vous savez
c'est comme les gens qui vous disent
qu'on compte qui on compte comme les
anti mac c'est des pros vague qui on
compte pour ceux qui sont pour certaines
choses et contredire les choses à un
moment donné c'est les chiffres macro la
croissance elle va nous permettre de
rembourser cette dette et d'améliorer
justement le remboursement doit faire
les français de marche donc je ne crois
pas qu'aujourd'hui forêt car il a
démontré
à démontrer madame tout reste à
démontrer ces bestioles caractéristique
c'est bien pour ça que tous les jours
ils sont sérieux arrêtez de dire alors
le porte-parole du gouvernement a
confirmé que la réforme des retraites
était bien toujours sur la table et que
certaines mesures pourraient même être
votée avant la fin du quinquennat
regardez nous n'avons jamais arrêté de
réformer y compris pendant la crise nous
allons amplifier notamment avec la
réforme de l'assurance chômage au 1er
octobre la question des retraites n'a
jamais quitté la table il n'y a rien
dans père et bruno bonnell une réforme
des retraites avant 2022 est ce que cela
ne risque pas d'attiser la colère
sociale il faut d'abord commencer par
arrêter de parler de la réforme des
retraites et je regrette gabriel attané
utiliser ce mot puisque ce n'est pas la
réforme des retraites telle qu'elle
avait été présenté d'une façon
systémique il ya quelques mois ce qui
est ce qu'il n'a jamais quitté la table
c'est direct toute façon faudra
équilibrer notre système de retraite
encore une fois pour la protection des
salariés je précise tout de suite pas
avoir l'argument dans exactement 14
secondes je précise tout de suite qui
effectivement les tms les conditions de
travail et le respect la santé des gens
seraient est intégré dans toute réforme
de retraite d'ailleurs elle était déjà
de ce que vit cette trêve ce projet de
réforme aujourd'hui c'est 1000 euros
2009 minimum de retraite pour tous les
gens c'est un élément important de
qualité de vie et 2 la fin des régimes
spéciaux ça s'arrête là quand on écoute
les françaises 80 % d'entre eux disent
nous on veut la fin des régimes spéciaux
ou considère comme justement soutien
inégalitaire à la retraite des uns
contre les autres ça je pense que l'art
est le cas la france est soumise ne peut
que soutenir cette idée qui font une
retraite plus égalitaire ça s'arrête là
elle n'a jamais quitté la table
vallières qu'on remet sur le couvert ce
qui s'est passé ce qui faisait quelques
mois au début de cette réforme emilie
marsh un commentaire sur cette réforme
ou en tout cas certaine mesure qui
pourrait déjà être
analysées et mise en place avant avant
la fin du mandat d' emmanuel macron je
veux faire donnant sur la réforme de
l'assurance chômage ça va permettre de
puces trier les jeux parce qu'il ya
aussi des gens qui sont rayés pôle
emploi de façon assez facile et aussi
sur les catégories on ne compte que la
catégorie à c'est à dire les gens qui
n'ont pas du tout travaillé mais si on a
travaillé une heure ou juste ou juste
une journée on n'est plus dans cette
catégorie donc à bien prendre les
chiffres dans dans dans son intégralité
parce que quand on est con travail que
deux semaines parce que les contrastes
sont de plus en plus courts à la fin du
mois c'est assez assez compliqué sur la
réforme des retraites va évidemment que
nous cette réforme nous nous la
combattons nous avons combattu nous la
combattons et nous la combattrons et que
en fait il ya une autre façon de
financer le système des retraites que
non la la retraite par points et
inégalitaire sur les régimes spéciaux
moi j'aurai une question à me poser à
monsieur bruno bonnell est-ce que c'est
tous les régimes spéciaux et les compris
celui des parlementaires qui est quoi
même aussi un très très intéressant pour
les parlementaires qui sera qui sera
revu est-ce que celui-là on l'entend
jamais et en fait il ya il ya une autre
façon de financer le système des
retraites qui est par exemple que si on
payait une femme autant qu'un homme ça
augmenterait les cotisations et ça
permettrait de financer la retraite à 60
ans la retraite à 60 ans tiens tiens
endroit et c'est aussi parce que à 60
ans notre corps il est fatigué mais
qu'on soit un ouvrier conçoit un cadre
conçoit et qu'on a le droit
après 60 ans de profiter de la vie et
c'est un système par solidarité qui a
été créée à l'issue de la seconde guerre
mondiale par ambroise croizat et qu'il
faut préserver et que non la part
productifs de la france on n'a jamais
été aussi riche on n'a jamais été autant
produit le problème c'est un problème de
répartition des richesses donc c'est
comment on répartit la richesse comment
ceux qui ont un plus hauts revenus on
augmente les cotisations sociales
pourrait que tout le monde ait le droit
à une retraite décente c'est à dire que
pour nous tout le monde a droit à une
retraite au mois égale smic bruno
bonnell revenons sur sur le slogan 50
plus qui va être le mot d'ordre pour
cette campagne pour le président un
slogan qui ressemble curieusement vous
allez voir à celui du président obama
lors de sa deuxième campagne électorale
fort myers quatre ans de plus la
république en large s'est elle inspirée
du président démocrate américain et et
autres questions dans la foulée le tract
est signée majorité présidentielle la
république en marche le nom du parti
n'apparaît plus pourquoi
justes pour rassurer madame ça marche
tout d'abord en 2010 est la première loi
qui a été votée par la majorité de la
république en marche c'était justement
la réforme des retraites des
parlementaires dont je vous rassure nous
n'avons plus du tout de régimes spéciaux
depuis que nous sommes au pouvoir mais
je suis très fier d'avoir soutenu cette
proposition de loi donc ça c'est juste
pour bien clarifier les choses il n'y a
pas de régimes spéciaux de retraite des
parlementaires tentent à votre marque
évidemment qu'il faut s'inspirer pas il
faut être inspiré par des gens qui ont
justement essayer de transformer la
philosophie de leur pays président obama
ont fait partie avec des succès et avec
des échecs comme toute gouvernance et ça
c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait
normal maintenant sur le slogan lui même
j'aurais juste vous dire qu'il est
signée majorité présidentielle parce que
justement nous pensions que à ce moment
de crise grave que nous venons de vivre
et qui j'espère dans les quelques mois
qui viennent sera derrière nous on n'a
pas fini on n'a pas fini je répète je
profite de votre antenne pour continuer
à dire ch vaccinez vous c'est important
et bien à ce moment de crise grave il
est important d'élargir cette majorité
de projet et que la république en marche
même en restant le parti le plus lourd
probablement dû de la combinaison global
de cette majorité présidentielle est
bien un peu s'associer au modem à agir à
territoire de progrès et pourquoi pas à
d'autres personnes qui sont eux qui sont
partantes pour construire le projet avec
le président emmanuel macron pour les
cinq ans qui viennent merci beaucoup ce
sera le mot de la fin on a pu le temps
malheureusement merci beaucoup bruno
bonnell et et merci à vous et emilie
marsh d'avoir participé à ce débat ce
matin